if you thought I was gonna come to
Austria and not do a pretty massive ski
jump you're out of your mind
Eddie the Eagles easily the biggest
legend in ski jumping history right [ __ ]
yeah
here he comes
[Music]
that's what makes Eddie the Eagle on the
legend
[Music]
meet my buddy James Lambert world
champion ski jumper and dumb enough to
put me on this son of a [ __ ] yeah love
it do a little warm-up jump on the
middle
[Music]
because
yeah and the Eagle what an honor to meet
this legendary man
now it's time to suck at ski jumping on
live TV
[Music]
so I suck dick at ski jumping but at
least I tried would you think of that
I'm here with Zachary and we're gonna
run up the impossible to run uphill yep
okay go
[Music]
six
it's my last day in Austria I'm thirsty
[Music]
every straight you guys alright
I don't want to bore you all with my
nostalgic tour of London but I lived
here from 1984 to 1986 and then 1988 to
and I came to visit this bench in 1989 I
painted this so that my skateboard would
slide better on it I just can't even
believe it's still there dog this is so
cool
and I just wanted to go visit my high
school I took pictures of all the kids
there
it was so [ __ ] cool man it needs more
pain
oh yeah he's professional he's done
before this done before
[Music]
so here in London England can I see some
other funny pictures oh yeah yeah okay
yeah we get the idea
[Applause]
[Music]
back home you can best believe it's time
to get totally rad I'm talking about
skateboard
amantha but first let's make sure to
stop because it is cotton gauze yeah
and make sure you subscribe
[Music]